[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de face aux territoires ici sur tv5monde
en direct ce matin avec nos partenaires
cette émission est regardable sur ouest
france.fr sur nicematin.com sur
franceantilles.fr avec un léger décalage
horaire du bien sûr aux fuseaux horaires
sur lamontagne.fr et sur 20minutes.fr
nos partenaires co producteur de cette
émission mon invité ce matin c'est bruno
le maire bonjour bruno le maire je suis
gay lettre le ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la relance c'est
important j'ai une première question à
vous poser qui concerne la france et ses
alliés européens
qui ont de canon ce qu'ils avaient
annoncé leur retrait dans takouba c'est
sur les forces spéciales bien sûr de
plusieurs pays européens ainsi que le
canada ils annoncent leur retrait
coordonné du mali une question ministre
de l'économie et des finances est ce que
ces opérations coûtent une fortune
est-ce que sa grève les finances
publiques est ce que vous êtes content
au fond que concernant
elles coûtent ces opérations extérieures
1,5 milliard d'euros par an l'ensemble
des opérations extérieures des armées
françaises c'est le prix de notre
sécurité et vous permettrez de saluer
l'engagement des soldats français sur
les tables d'opérations extérieures en
particulier au mali parce que ces
soldats ont risqué leur vie certains
l'ont perdue pour notre sécurité à nous
tous pour lutter contre le terrorisme et
pour garantir notre sécurité sur
l'ensemble du territoire français dont
je voudrais vraiment leur robe rendre un
hommage appuyé sincère parce que ils ont
garanti notre protection au péril de
leur vie alors bruno le maire c'est le
miz l'économie des finances de la
relance une amélioration sur le terrain
sanitaire clair vous vous félicitez d'un
rebond de la croissance il y a des
promesses de dépenses nouvelles chaque
jour dans la campagne présidentielle et
dans son rapport annuel publié hier
pierre moscovici qui est le premier
président de la cour des comptes parle
d' efforts sans précédent a réalisé il
parle de 9 milliards d'euros d'économies
supplémentaires par an c'est la rigueur
version 1984 qui nous attend juste après
la présidentielle comme par hasard ou
pas non je ne crois pas je
partage l'appréciation de pierre
moscovici bien entendu qu'il faut des
finances yannis de l'économie des
finances et derrière c'est bien tenu
mais je pense que simplement prendre un
petit peu de recul sur ce que nous avons
fait et sur ce que nous voulons faire
avec le présent la république nous nous
avons établi des finances publiques
serrées de begin nous sommes revenus
sous les 3% de déficit en 2018 et nous
avons avec cette majorité qui a le
rétablissement des finances publiques
dans son adn nous avons sorti la france
de la procédure pour déficit excessif
ensuite nous avons une crise majeure et
nous avons fait un choix stratégique
avec emmanuel macron qui est de protéger
des salariés et de protéger des
entreprises ce choix là il était bon
économique - des t bonds socialement il
était bon politiquement il était bon
aussi pour nos finances publiques parce
que c'est moins cher de protéger que de
réparer les dégâts du chômage et le
dégâts des fakes maintenant que nous
avons bien protégé pas la conséquence de
ça c'est quoi c'est que l'économie
française démarre mieux que les autres
économies européennes plus vite plus
fort cette source de croissance et un
million d'emplois qui ont été créés au
cours du quinquennat nous redémarrons
vite et nous redémarrerons fort parce
que nous avons bien protégé mais ensuite
je n'ai jamais fait de mystère nous
allons devoir re table ira nouveau les
finances publiques simplement nous
allons le faire soit pas une stratégie
différente de celle qui a échoué au
cours des dernières décennies
l'austérité et la rigueur ça ne marche
pas ça conduit à plus de dettes plus
difficile plus de chômage et moins de
croissance
nous notre stratégie c'est d'abord la
croissance et l'investissement
les réformes de structure et les
économies là où c'est nécessaire et bien
vous en parle et dont vous l'avez
compris c'est bruno le maire le ministre
de l'économie des finances et de la
relance qui est notre invité ce matin
d'en face aux territoires dans un
instant françois xavier lefrançois
rejoint sur ce plateau
[Musique]
bonjour françois xavier le franc lourd
vous êtes le rédacteur en chef de ouest
france le premier quotidien francophone
du monde il faut le rappeler et nous
allons parler de choix de nucléaire oui
ou non le maire bonjour vous dans le
maire on parle beaucoup de l'énergie
c'est normal on est en campagne
électorale c'est un sujet extrêmement
important on parle beaucoup de nucléaire
alors vous avez prononcé le jour une
petite phrase qui a fait beaucoup parler
en expliquant que dans les scénarios
possibles il y avait celui de la
nationalisation d'edf alors on va parler
des deux de ce qu'on demande à edf
aujourd'hui c'est un chantier colossal
le nucléaire est ce que ça veut dire que
dans les structures actuelles on ne peut
pas faire confiance et à edf ou que de
coco df n'est pas en mesure de remplir
sa mission et ce qu'on attend d'elle
dans les mois qui viennent pourquoi
parler de nationalisation nous avons une
confiance totale dans edf et edf a le
soutien de l'état l'edf l'entreprise et
les salariés des talons quand vous
regardez les cathares 4% et on a
additionné à 95% l'état soutient df et
continuera de soutenir des f edf a connu
au cours des dernières années un certain
nombre de difficultés
l'indisponibilité d'un certain nombre
des réacteurs est aujourd'hui la
principale difficulté qui pèsent sur edf
et qui pèse sur les comptes d'edf c'est
ça aujourd'hui qui pèse le plus sur les
résultats et sur les comptes d'edf le
président république est venu à belfort
il a annoncé une nouvelle stratégie
énergétique qui repose sur d'abord des
économies d'énergie c'est le plus
important il faut faire attention à
l'énergie que nous dépensons faut faire
preuve de sobriété en matière d'énergie
le déploiement d'énergie renouvelable
beaucoup plus vite que ce qui avait été
prévu et puis la création de six
réacteurs six nouveaux jeux p r et 8 qui
sont mis à l'étude qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire que edf a pour les
décennies qui viennent un plan de charge
totalement rempli c'est une excellente
nouvelle pour edf et nous nous sommes
déterminés à accompagner ses
investissements et à faire en sorte qu
edf puisque les réaliser dans les
meilleures conditions alors s'il faudra
évidemment beaucoup d'argent et c'est
plus facile d'emprunter quand on est à
l'étape quand on est une entreprise
privée donc on peut penser que c'est ça
aussi j'imagine qu'ils
qui qui fait que demain df pour être
complètement nationalisée ma
responsabilité c'est de regarder ce dont
edf a besoin pour réaliser dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
financière économique en termes aussi
d'emploi de formation et de
qualification
le projet et la ligne qui étaient fixées
par le présent arrêt peu mais comment
faire pour que edf réalise le mieux
possible ces chantiers renouvelables et
ses chantiers nucléaires en
l'accompagnant de toutes les manières
possibles nous garantissant cet
accompagnement jeu pas précisé quelle
forme il prendra mais l'etat sera aux
côtés d'edf comme il l'a toujours été
alors le nucléaire c'est un peu parfois
vu comme l'industrie de la démesure
notamment en matière de 2,2 en matière
de budget
six nouveaux réacteurs ces 50 milliards
à peu près quand on pense à le père de
flamanville qui en arrive aujourd'hui à
près de 19 milliards si l'on compte le
coût des emprunts si on pense demain au
coût du démantèlement des centrales
nucléaires plus tard dans les années qui
viennent on se dit que c'est des sommes
d'argent faramineuses est ce qu'on
arrive à le suivre la vraie des mesures
je vais vous dire elle est sur les
besoins en électricité
et je crois qu'il faut que chacun prenne
conscience que les besoins en
électricité explose en france et vont
exploser en france comme en europe parce
que vous aurez des véhicules électriques
parce qu'il faut faire tourner les
usines d'électrolysé qui vont faire de
l'hydrogène vert parce que vous avez la
5g tout ça demande des besoins en
électricité des carbo des massifs le
choix stratégiques il est simple est-ce
que vous voulez dépendre des pays
étrangers où est ce que voulait produire
cette électricité décarbonés vous même
nous nous avons une chance nous avons
électricité nucléaire est bien le choix
que nous avons fait avec elle elle
macron c'est un choix de souveraineté et
d'indépendance totale nous voulons
produire nous mêmes notre et déclare
qu'il faut produire l'électricité en
2022 la production d'edf sera la plus
faible je crois depuis 30 ans vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure et le sujet
vous êtes parfaitement il ya un certain
nombre de réacteurs qui sont à l'arrêt
parce qu'il faut faire des il faut faire
des contrôles il faut voir s'il ya pas d
de corrosion et en amont le rond on le
sait donc c'est un pari technologique et
beaucoup disent il va falloir comme on
dirait augmenter la durée de vie des
réacteurs peut être au delà de 50 ans
quelles garanties on a sur le plan
technologique que c'est possible ça la
garantie c'est l'asn c'est à l'autorité
de sûreté nucléaire nous avons les
normes de sûreté qui sont les plus sûrs
au monde sait parfaitement légitime
parce que nous avons un parc nucléaire
qui est important c'est l'asn et l'asn
seul qui en toute indépendance nous dit
vous pouvez prolonger vous ne pouvez pas
prolongé ou vous pouvez prolonger à
certaines conditions le point qui est
essentiel c'est de retrouver des
compétences nucléaires de classe
mondiale comme nous avons créé une
l'avons été mono le maire mais comme
nous l'avons été comme nous devons leur
devenir mais évidemment à force de dire
le nucléaire c'est fini a forcément les
jeunes qui pourraient devenir
chaudronnier soudeur ingénieurs
techniciens de maintenance ils se
détournent des métiers là avec ce plan
de charge avec ce qu'a annoncé le
président de la république l'énergie
nucléaire est la filière nucléaire va
retrouver le prestige qu'elle aurait
jamais dû perdre les jeunes les jeunes
justement aujourd'hui nous sommes en
campagne électorale on va beaucoup
parler de la dette la dette française
qui pourrait approcher les 3000
milliards d'euros dans le courant de
l'année 2022 la dette c'est un peu
aujourd'hui un machin qu'on utilise pour
faire peur dans le discours politique
qu'est ce que vous diriez aux jeunes
générations pour leur expliquer que la
dette n'est pas un cadeau empoisonné que
ça peut être peut-être à levier de
développement économique
parce que à chaque fois que vous avez en
face de vous vos opposants on vous amène
évidemment l'histoire de la dette et
quand on ne met pas au fait des choses
on se dit vous l'avez c'est énorme s'est
levé l'admets mais opposant d'avant le
font sourire est-ce que l'explosion des
dettes comme le dit très bien pierre
moscovici la romance ya 15 ans donc en
général c'est ce que l'on fait exploser
la dette avec les mauvaises stratégies
qui en plus a mené plus de chômage et
moins de croissance qui viennent vous
faire l'algérie à penser n'est crédible
vous avez appartenir à des gouvernements
précédents d'accord mais alors qu'est la
culture on n'est pas responsable de la
bête qu'est ce que vous direz l'âge de
ministre des finances je suis
responsable de la belle est ce que vous
diriez aux jeunes je dirais aux jeunes
première chose c'est qu'ils peuvent nous
faire confiance nous avons rétabli je le
rappelle les finances publiques en 2017
et 2018 ce que n'avait pas été fait
depuis le début des années 2000 et que
nous reviendrons à ce rétablissement des
finances publiques mais avec une
stratégie
je vraiment insister sur ce point qui
est différente pas la rigueur on pas
l'austérité parce que ça on a essayé la
croissance à couper à la hache à
l'aveuglent dans la dépense publique
dans le nombre de fonctionnaires qu'est
ce que ça a donné en 2012 serait
exactement moins de croissance plus de
chômage et plus de dette donc nous avons
mis sur pied une stratégie différente
que de dire on investit on crée de la
croissance et la croissance nous donne
des marges de manoeuvre qui sont
absolument considérable 20 milliards
d'euros de recettes fiscales
supplémentaires qui nous ont permis en
2021 de ramener la dette de 115 à 113%
et déficit qui devait être de 8,2 à 7%
le coeur de notre stratégie c'est la
croissance et l'investissement ensuite
il faut évidemment des réformes de
structure mais là aussi je dis aux
jeunes qui nous écoutent pouvez nous
faire confiance on les a faites qui a
fait la réforme l'assurance chômage qui
a fait la réforme du droit du travail
qui a fait la simplification pour la vie
d'entreprise ce et nono et enfin le
dernier point pour je n'oublie pas le
dernier pilier de sa stratégie frais dit
évidemment il faut réduire les dépenses
publiques en utilisant la numérisation
la digitalisation on l'a fait par
exemple sur le prélèvement à la source
peut très bien le faire sur les
prestations sociales par des prestations
sociales qui soit mieux calibrée donc
chacun puisse bénéficier quand il y as
droit et qui en même temps soit plus
économe du nombre de fonctionnaires
c'est bruno le maire de mise et
l'économie des finances de la relance
qui est notre invité à une tradition
dans cette émission show nuque et
collaborateurs de ouest-france et
dessinateur à une question à vous poser
en garde
monsieur le ministre à l'instant vous
avez évoqué la possible réforme des
droits de succession eh bien ma question
et des taux trouver de qui emmanuel
macron héritiers de de gaulle de giscard
de mitterrand de chira de sarkozy ou
deux tous ses prédécesseurs
en même temps
je pense que l'héritage dont il se
revendique et dont je me revendique
aussi ce qui fait que nous travaillons
bien ensemble
la sellette héritage gaulliste le coeur
du gaullisme c'est le dépassement du
clivage droite gauche et c'est le refus
des partis moi ça me va très bien je
pardonne deux parties donc ça me va très
bien et le dépassement de la droite et
de la gauche
c'est ce qui donne des résultats
est ce que c'est ce qui permet à la fois
de supprimer lié cfp alléger la
fiscalité sur le capital de mettre en
place son jeu derrière un peu des dents
le monde tous et dans le même temps deux
ans de soutenir ceux qui en ont
réellement besoin ceux qui ont besoin du
soutien de l'état de mettre en place le
quoi qu'il en coûte donc je vous crois
vraiment que la filiation des mails
macron c'est une filiation gaulliste à
une nourrice france pense à terry
lefranc mellal de ouest-france la
précarité étudiante parce que c'est une
réalité et puis un sujet qui vous est
cher la défense de la langue française
très bien on passe tout de suite à denis
carot de nice matin qui nous rejoint sur
ce plateau dans un instant
[Musique]
bonjour denis carot bonjour bonjour le
directeur de la rédaction du groupe nice
matin vous intéressez évidemment à la
réindustrialisation de la france tout un
sujet oui bruno le maire vous estimiez
il y à quelques temps que la puissance
d'une nation se mesure à son commerce
extérieur
or le déficit du commerce extérieur a
atteint un niveau sans précédent et on
voit bien que notre industrie a du mal à
relever la tête après trente ans de
déclin alors comment peut-on
concrètement est vraiment inverser la
tendance produire davantage et
relocaliser des activités l'abandon
commencé à inverser la tendance la
première fois depuis des décennies nous
recréons des emplois industriels c'est
modeste mais nous créons des emplois
industriels nous avons plus d'usinés qui
ont ouvert en 2021 que des usines qui
ont fermé tant que nous sommes dans la
bonne direction et surtout dur créant de
nouvelles filières industrielles temps
prenez juste les batteries électriques
ont les uns porté à 85% au début du
quinquennat de chine ou de corée
aujourd'hui on va les produira douvrin
dans le nord de la france on allait
produire à dunkerque en valais produire
sur le territoire français avec des
usines françaises et les ouvriers
français prenez les semi conducteurs on
va développer la production de semi
conducteurs en france prenait
l'hydrogène vers fantastique
développement industriel possible pour
la france dans les années qui viennent
avec des milliers d'emplois à la clef
pour la réalisation des usines et pour
l'électro lice donc nous allons réussir
cette reconquête industrielle il ya deux
conditions la première elle commence à
être remplie c'est que ça coûte moins
cher donc on a baissé les impôts de
production et vous savez je suis
favorable à ce que nous poursuivions la
baisse des impôts de production puis la
deuxième condition là souvent les gens
sont un peu plus rétifs signer bah oui
faut simplifier l'installation
d'industries et de sites industriels en
france il faut qu'il y est c'est une
proposition que je fais plus que un seul
niveau de recours quand on veut attaquer
l'installation d'une usine et pas deux
ou trois je propose soit le conseil
d'état dans lequel une chambre
spécifique il ya un recours possible une
fois qu'il est traité on ouvre lusine
ont créé des emplois qui vont avec en il
faut former et qualifier c'est aussi un
des grands défis on a un autre problème
aussi c'est le manque de compétences
comment faire en sorte d'avoir les
bonnes compétences au bon endroit on a
beaucoup d'entreprises qui ont du mal à
recruter aujourd'hui et c'est un frein
c'est le problème numéro un pour
l'industrie c'est le problème numéro un
c'est celui qui est plus complexe à
traiter qui demande une révolution
culturelle que chacun comprenne que
l'industrie c'est l'avenir de la france
et pas son passé que ses créateurs
d'emplois que ça ne rime pas avec
destructions d'emplois que ses propres
que c'est pas sale que c'est
technologiquement avancé et que ça
n'appartient pas au dix neuvième siècle
c'est cette révolution culturelle qu'il
faut opérer moi j'ai des propositions
très concrètes ont fait visiter à des
collégiens des musées des sites
culturels formidable mais qu'ils
puissent aussi visité des juges ont
donné envie les lieux de fabrication
pour leur donner envie parce que ça fait
partie de notre culture et c'est quand
même passionnant quand on était un gamin
de 11 12 ou 13 ans d'aller visiter une
usine on fabrique des airbus des avions
des bateaux les rues de saint-nazaire
autres et ensuite revalorisé comme ça où
commencer à le faire l'apprentissage les
métiers industriels en montrant qu'ils
sont qualifiés bien payés porteur
d'avenir bruno le maire mise de
l'économie et des finances et de la
relance est notre invité ce matin télé
78 a rencontré pierre bédier vous allez
le voir président du conseil
départemental des yvelines qui a une
question à vous poser à propos du
secteur automobile bien aimée par denis
carot
nous avons assisté en dise à poissy qui
va créer son campus vert regrouper ses
forces de recherche et développement et
dessert nous avons renoué à flins à
flins aubergenville qui va créer la
première usine empreinte carbone négatif
alors monsieur le ministre mes chers
bruit vont nous voudrions savoir et nous
attendons avec impatience nous les élus
et les habitants des yvelines ce que
l'état va faire pour cette filière
automobile ô combien nécessaire à
l'industrie française dont je salue mon
ami pierre bédier
l'état a déjà beaucoup fait pour la
firme automobile avec un plan de 15
milliards d'euros de soutien à la
filière automobile nous avons soutenues
pendant la crise et je pense que c'est
un bon exemple si ça redémarre aussi
vite c'est que les ouvriers de flins
dont te parler pierre bédier les
ingénieurs du centre de recherche de
renault ils ont continué à travailler
pendant la crise tant qu'ils peuvent
redémarrer plus vite ensuite nous nous
accompagnons tout des investissements
pour la décarbonation de l'industrie que
ce soit l'automobile l'aéronautique les
investissements dans les batteries
électriques nous participons à ces
investissements là nous voulons que
l'automobile réussisse sa révolution
technologique vers le véhicule connecté
et va le véhicule et le d6 et l'anti
serono sont en train d'y arriver c'est
un défi considérable ils sont en train
d'y arriver le défi est considérable
effectivement et l'automobile
l'industrie automobile est confronté une
révolution radicale on estime que d'ici
2030 50 mille emplois pourraient
disparaître notamment dans la sous
traitance comment faire pour éviter ce
que ce scénario catastrophe il faut
accompagner toutes les pme tous les
sites industriels qui effectivement on
voit être menacée prenez ce que nous
avons fait sur la sidérurgie sur les
fonderies on sait bien que les fonderies
aujourd'hui ils vont avoir moins de
volume parce que quand vous passez d'un
bloc thermique qui a beaucoup d'acier
beaucoup d'aluminium un bloc électrique
où il ya beaucoup moins d'aluminium
forcément les fonderies ont un plan de
charge qui est plus faible il faut
accompagner prenez l'exemple du site de
decazeville avec la sam on cherche un
repreneur
pour la sam et j'ai bon espoir qu'on
arrive en trouver un sur le site de deux
cases ville on va réindustrialiser le
site notamment avec leur traitement des
batteries électriques au cas de nouveaux
métiers qui vont être créées par la
décarbonation il faut que tous les
salariés tous les ouvriers qui
travaillaient dans des secteurs qui vont
être fragilisés puissent être
accompagnés personnellement
individuellement pour aller vers ces
deux hommes et tient justement nous
allons à clermont ferrand monsieur le
miz économie et des finances ou la
montagne à notre partenaire la montagne
centre france à une question à vous
poser de laurent bernard journaliste à
la montagne à propos de l'aéronautique
bruno le maire bonjour le déficit
commercial record de la france en 2021
s'explique en partie par les difficultés
du secteur aéronautique
en auvergne le groupe constellium qui
fabrique des alliages d'aluminium pour
les avionneurs mondiaux ressent des
signes de reprise et s'apprête même à
réembaucher dans le même temps le
président macron a fixé comme objectif
aux industriels français d'arriver à un
avion da carbone d'ici 2030 pouvez vous
nous dire quelles sont les perspectives
pour le secteur dans les prochaines
années je vais très rapide et productifs
sont excellentes j'étais hier à toulouse
j'ai discuté avec le président d'airbus
guillaume faury fait un travail
remarquable quel problème aujourd'hui
l'aéronautique et le problème d'airbus
c'est pas un problème de demande un
problème d'offre sait comment répondre
aux milliers de commandes d'airbus a320
neo que airbus le dire c'est un désert
blême mais pour aller nous le vrai
problème n'est pas celui que l'on croit
c'est pas un problème d'aéronautique ou
d'aviation qui réduirait le son volume
et aurait des commandes insuffisantes
c'est exactement l'inversé il ya des cas
les commandes qui sont pleins mais il
faut simplement que les sous traitants
airbus arrive à suivre la cadence mais
j'aurai ainsi sur un point clé est ce
que j'entends les critiques très
rapidement c'est parce que nous avons
protégé les ingénieurs les salariés des
sous traitants l'ensemble des
techniciens qui travaillent chez airbus
un fier aéronautique que lorsque vous
avez toutes les compagnies aériennes du
monde qui commandent des a320neo on peut
ré ouvrir une usine est une chaîne de
montage à toulouse et on peut répondre à
la demande ouvrir nos stratégies d la
bonne alors sur le numérique c'est vrai
que messi n'a qu'à pdg de maille coach
40 à nice matin d'ailleurs une question
à vous poser
monsieur milices bonjour on voit que
l'actualité autour de la souveraineté
numérique bat son plein les élections
présidentielles vont encore plus
l'accentuer comment aujourd'hui après un
mandat réussi en faire votre dernier
cheval de bataille comment aujourd'hui
être à la hauteur de ce qui se passe
dans les pays étrangers notamment aux
états unis et répondre en fait au delà
d'une législation contraignante au
niveau européenne par une souveraineté
la française
voilà de souveraineté ces deux choses
c'est se protéger c'est investir je
commence d'abord par investir quand on
soutient les start up de la tête quand
on leur permet de lever de l'argent plus
facilement elles peuvent grossir elle
résiste mieux ça garantit notre
souveraineté numérique d'avoir nos
propres acteurs et puis c'est se
protéger faut pas être naïf ya des
attaques et des attaques cyber j'ai
inauguré la connu d'ailleurs bien sûr
mais les attaques cyber ça touche les
hôpitaux ça peut toucher les chaînes de
télévision ça peut toucher des
infrastructures critiques donc nous
avons inauguré un campus cyber à la
défense qui a vocation à être un des
meilleurs au monde pour nous protéger
contre les attaques sévères il vient
d'ouvrir 1800 personnes des start up des
grands prix comme notre thales ou
d'autres qui vont atos capgemini qui
vont travailler dans ce site là et
garantir la protection française contre
les attaques cyber denis carot je
voudrais revenir à l'automobile l'ancien
président de renault carlos ghosn vous a
violemment mis en cause dimanche dans
une interview au parisien il estime
notamment que c'est vous qui vous êtes
manifesté le de la manière la plus
hostile envers lui vous l'avez vraiment
laissé tomber carlos ghosn non
est ce que il a bénéficié de la
protection de l'état français continue
ses déboires judiciaires au japon oui
oui les droits la protection judiciaire
à laquelle a droit n'importe quel
citoyen français lorsque il est
confronté
oui mais ce pont ça c'est pardon mais
c'est anecdotique il a droit une
protection judiciaire lui accorder comme
n'importe quel citoyen français il fait
manifeste son un reproche sur le fait
que j'aurai lancé je crois un contrôle
fiscal en tentant de lui et c'est ça
c'est vrai c'est un mensonge
cette année son personnel pour pourquoi
c'est là dedans c'est un mensonge de
bordeaux première raison c'est qu'à
l'époque je n'avais pas là tu t'es de la
direction générale des finances
publiques qui fait le contrôle fiscal
donc même si j'avais voulu faire je
n'aurais pas pu le faire et que par
ailleurs depuis que j'ai la tutelle de
la direction générale des finances
publiques ma conception du rôle des
musées des finances c'est que il ne
lance pas de contrôle fiscal ce n'est
pas seul sur lequel vous devez pas de
contentieux commercial entre vous mais
aucun jeu simplement jouer mon rôle de
ministre qui est actionnaire neuronaux
c'est à dire prendre des décisions qui
sont bonnes pour renault pour laisser la
grille également à mieux aider gernot ou
pas parce que je sais c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une très bonne
direction de renault que nous aider mais
aucun la période mais
cette période là est tournée nous avons
un nouveau directeur général qui va
trahir au munster le bo vous considérez
vous êtes un expert va miser économie
sciences que la perte ghosn a été
prolifique pour renault bonne moisson
des indices cyril viguier je vous le
redis c'est l'avenir de renault c'est
qu'il réussisse la révolution à vous
faire gestion mais je pourrais avoir
étendu très clairement à ce qui a été
dit 1 j'ai fait ce qui était nécessaire
de l'état a garanti à carlos ghosn la
protection laquelle ils avaient droit 3
je veux rétablir la vérité sur cette
histoire de contrôle fiscal vous avez
refait pur mensonge je tiens le faire
parce que le milieu des finances ne
lance pas de jante arrière fiscal ça
n'est pas de son rôle et ça n'est pas sa
mission est en revanche veut vraiment
insister sur le travail remarquable que
fait le nouveau président de renault
jean dominic sena et son directeur
général luca de meo parce que ils ont
une stratégie pour réussir la révolution
technologique vers le véhicule
électrique qui me paraît très porteuse
avec des étapes qui sont claires avec un
calendrier clair je suis certain que ça
donnera de bons résultats pour air est
ma seule préoccupation je le redis
serono la marque l'air si les salariés
et les sites industriels qui vont avec
la une de nice fin d'un très violent on
reste dans l'automobile 1 comment rouler
moins cher tous nos conseils pour
éviter de payer trop cher à la pompe
voilà nous partons pour fort-de-france
merci denis carot un autre journal du
groupe auquel vous appartenez france
antilles
depuis fort de france s'il aboutit à une
question à poser à bono le maire notre
invité ce matin
bonjour ou non le maire vous avez évoqué
les questions de pouvoir d'achat la vie
chère dans les territoires d'outre-mer
est un sujet particulièrement important
des prix élevés qui résulte de nos
systèmes de distribution parfois même de
monopole dans la distribution des
monopoles
que le président de la république a
souvent évoqué et souhaitait faire
tomber ça faisait partie des annonces
lors de sa précédente campagne
présidentielle où en est on
alors on en étant bruno le maire des 1er
et emmanuel macron qui date de 2017
alors sur tout ce qui est tout et
territoires d'outre-mer neutre comme
n'importe quel autre territoire français
notre préoccupation première était
protégé contre la crise donc je
reconnais bien volontiers qu'on a pu
prendre du retard sur certains projets
ont été annoncés par le président la
république mais on s'est d'abord assuré
qu' il y avait la protection des
salariés qu'il y avait l'activité
partielle qui avait les prêts garantis
par l'état s'est beaucoup occupé aussi
les compagnies aériennes qui desservent
et territoires d'outre-mer parce
qu'elles ont rencontré des difficultés
considérables nous avons massivement
soutenu financièrement et on va
reprendre ensuite le fil de ce que nous
devions faire sur les questions de
monopole des questions de prix qui sont
effectivement majeur armelle le goff
directrice de la rédaction de 20 minutes
notre partenaire bonjour bonjour
ministre les salles de spectacle les
discothèques rouvre depuis hier alors ça
y est c'est le retour de la bamboche
c'est le retour de la bombe auger
participe activement d'ailleurs hier
soir josé en bonheur que nous hisser à 2
heures du matin vous avez la retraite de
toulouse et je ne suis pas allé en bonne
chose et pour les conditions c'est une
très bonne chose pour toutes les
françaises et tous les français qui ont
besoin de fête aux bonnes se retrouver
ils ont besoin de vie sociale c'est un
honnêtement ça a été pour tout le monde
cette période de soin de confinement
soit de restrictions sanitaires un
moment l'humain da difficile vous l'avez
alors la bamboche pas pour tout le monde
20 minutes a publié un article tout
récemment sur les conditions de travail
dans la restauration on a une lectrice
amis qui nous raconte qu'elle est
serveuse à chambéry qu'elle a travaillé
28 jours d'affilée avec seulement trois
jeux amy de congé on sait que la
restauration peine à recruter on peut
comprendre avec ses conditions de
travail non oui mais je pense que si il
ya bien un secteur qui est lucide sur la
nécessité d'améliorer les conditions de
travail dans son secteur c'est
l'hôtellerie les cafés les restaurants
c'est que c'est un secteur dont je suis
très proche je considère ce fait partie
de la vie à la française de l'art de
vivre à la française j'ai eu des
réunions en plus savoir soit avec le
secteur soit avec des copains qui sont
hôteliers restaurateurs jeudi vous ils
vous n'êtes pas trop où est inhumée vous
prenant des cafés
plus agréable de prendre un café en
terrasse de l'art de vivre à la fin du
bol d'air mais
les discussions que nous avons eues ont
été très franche année vous pouvez pas
demander un jeune qui a 20 22 ans de
venir faire le service de 13 heures et
puis ensuite entre 15h et 18h ne pas lui
offrir la possibilité soit de se loger
squad attendant de bonnes conditions
après quand vous voulez vous qu'ils
reprennent son service tout ça c'est dur
les conditions devaient être améliorées
les hôteliers les restaurateurs ont
parfaitement conscience ils ont fait un
effort si j'en fais un effort très
important surtout c'est à ce que ce soit
le cas en revanche il y a plein d'autres
branches vous réclamez des efforts sur
les rémunérations ça ne se fait pas les
salariés de dassault par exemple sont en
grève depuis plusieurs mois est-ce que
vous ne pourriez pas être un petit peu
plus coercitif sur cette question des
salaires et des rémunérations qui est un
vrai sujet aujourd'hui encore c'est un
vrai sujet notre méthode n'est pas la
coercition mais reste une autre méthode
c'est de redire à toutes les branches à
tous les secteurs où les niveaux de
rémunération sont trop faibles il faut
que vous offriez des conditions de
rémunération qu'ils soient meilleurs là
où vous pouvez le faire ça bouge dans
l'hôtellerie ça bougeait dans
l'hôtellerie dans les cafés dans les
restaurants ça a bougé chez les routiers
ça doit bouger aussi dans d'autres
secteurs ce que je leur dis très
sincèrement l'état a fait sa part du
chemin avec les primes défiscaliser avec
la prime d'activité avec je le rappelle
la baisse des charges début du
quinquennat pour tous les salariés
maintenant c'est aux entreprises dans
les secteurs où elles le peuvent de
faire un effort pour leurs salariés qui
mérite effectivement la reconnaissance
de leur travail bruno le maire notre
invité ce matin autre préoccupation des
français vous le savez thierry dieu
qu'est lecteurs de 20 minutes à une
question à vous poser
il est préoccupé comme un très grand
nombre de nos compatriotes bruno le
maire par le prix à la pompe 4 monsieur
le maire vous annoncer à chacune de vos
interviews que pc l'essence d'un centime
serait un manque à gagner de 500
millions d'euros pour l'état or depuis
un an l'essence a augmenté en moyenne de
32 centimes soit selon vos propres
calculs un gain de 16 milliards d'euros
pour l'état de plus pendant la guerre du
golfe les prix du pétrole était au plus
haut or les sens c'était moins cher
qu'aujourd'hui comment expliquez vous ça
vous donnait vraiment l'impression de
prendre les français pour des pigeons
le vrai pigeons dans la sphère si je
puis dire c'est l'état j'ai jamais pris
les français pour des pigeons jeu là
pour aider les français je rappelle
juste que depuis le début de l'année il
pourrait janvier nous devons dépenser 15
5 milliards d'euros ces deux recettes si
les gens ne le méritons je ne sais pas à
prendre mais je pars de les gens c'est
leur sentiment sur les gens auront
parfaitement ressenti aussi que
contrairement à ce qui se passe dans
tous les autres pays européens nous
avons évité la flambée des prix
d'électricité 4% pas plus en doute pays
ces 50 % 100 % nous écartons sens là
pour vous la verrez du gaz oui mais un
budget c'est global enfin budget c'est
l'essence et l'électricité c'est le gars
c'est le loyer ses loisirs des enfants
un budget dans une famille et j'ai
quatre enfants ses global ya pas un
budget essence qui occupe le budget
intégrale de la famille ou du ménage
donc je crois que les français savent
que nous les avons massivement protéger
contre l'augmentation des prix de
l'électricité des prix du gaz je pars
redire ça veut dire en gros sur le prix
à la pompe vous ne pourrez pas faire
grand chose non je dis que je regarde de
très près ce qui se passe sur les prix à
la pompe je suis extrêmement attentifs
extrêmement vigilants je regarde tous
les jours ce que donnent ces prix à la
pompe je dis simplement l'état a déjà
fait beaucoup et l'état évidemment
perdre de l'argent entreprises
indépendantes pour des pigeons il ne
semblait pas dans les poches alors on va
tout de suite regardé la une de
20minutes.fr le rôle des jeunes
militants dans une campagne notamment
sur les réseaux et les plateformes
numériques et je voulais vous demander
ce que vous pensiez du slogan des jeunes
avec macro n'avez pas envie de vous
ses envies 2 on envie de tout le monde
on a envie que tout le monde puisse
cesser la politique vous avez des idées
des convictions on envie que tout le
monde le soutiennent c'est une action
presque plus facile pour vous la
dernière fois je rappelle les
spectateurs vous vous étiez candidat
avec son présidentielle donc pour vous
c'est presque plus simple aujourd'hui ah
oui c'est beaucoup plus confortable de
ne pas être un leader je vous le
confirme surtout c'est très bien de
soutenir un candidat dans lequel on
croit il l'est pas encore tout à fait
c'est pas de ta mon agenda mais voilà le
jour où il sera candidat parce que je
pense que ça peut énerver je serais très
heureux de le soutenir et très engagé
très mobilisés voilà dans un instant
tv5monde sur ce plateau avec sylvia
garcia merci beaucoup armés le gop
[Musique]
bonjour sylvia garcia alors un sommet
très important le sommet europe-afrique
entre l'union européenne et l'union
africaine ça démarre tout à l'heure le
président français emmanuel macron appel
à refonder un new deal économique et
financier avec l'afrique notamment et je
le cite encore pour aller au bout de
cette solidarité à l'égard des africains
les africains veulent de la coopération
pas dns que ce sommet ne part pas sur le
bon vieux malentendu habituel jeu je
pense pas je pense qu'au contraire l'un
des grands mérites du pesant la
république c'est de solder le passé de
solder ses malentendus il construit
cette coopération sur des bases
nouvelles dans cette opération elle est
indispensable jeune justin chiffres les
pays développés ils ont consacré 25 % de
la richesse nationale à se protéger face
à la crise économique qui a relancé dans
l'économie mais dans quoi ça va très
bien pour ça on démarre les empereurs
sont la fin c'est tout ce qu'on a décrit
pendant notre émission c'est vrai
particulièrement en france c'est vrai
dans d'autres pays développés des
africains c'est à peine 2 % leur
richesse nationale donc ils ont pris la
crise économique de plein fouet notre
responsabilité c'est de les aider à s'en
sortir la fumée fédéral de la
coopération donc c'est ça la question
qui va se poser ce moment à ce sommet
qu'est ce que ça veut dire l afrique est
ce que propose l'europe à l'afrique elle
propose à l'afrique d'aider ses propres
entreprises c'est propre pmc propres
jeunes qui veulent créer leur start up à
se développer c'est ça qui est nouveau
c'est pas simplement des versets de là
argent dans des états c et d des
entreprises et pme des start up dans les
états concernés ça peut être la côte
d'ivoire le sénégal tous les états
africains à se développer sur la base de
leurs propres forces et leurs propres
ressources c'est un partenariat d'égal à
égal et chacun doit comprendre une chose
le destin de l'europe et le destin de
l'afrique sont étroitement liées dans ce
contexte international qui est très
mouvementée en ce moment l'europe a plus
besoin de l'afrique la verse et les deux
des deux continents ont besoin l'un de
l'autre il y aura pas de développement
européen son développement africain il
n'y aura pas de développement africain
sans développement européen l'union
européenne entend mobiliser d'ici à 2027
plus de 150 milliards d'euros
d'investissements européens dans des
projets d'infrastructures en afrique
c'est un recyclage den déjà envoyé d'où
vient cet argent comme annoncé il faut
du recyclage peut être des nouveaux
projets s'est des projets qui sont
indispensables pour améliorer la qualité
de l'environnement améliorer la qualité
des transports de quand on construit des
métros quand on construit les trains
c'est des millions d'africains qui vont
pouvoir en bénéficier et en profiter
mais je le redis sur une base d'égal à
égal nous nous voulons un continent
africain formé que la partie cet argent
comment on répartit ses 150 milliards
quel pays on veut bien toute la
difficulté aujourd'hui la france
l'europe se retire du m'allier avec
barkan comment on répartit à qui on
donne et sur quels critères ben on donne
sur les critères de projets qui peuvent
exister quand vous avez des états
africains qui ont des projets très
précis qui sont dans l'intérêt de ces
états qui sont aussi dans notre intérêt
a pas taddei d'égal à égal ça veut dire
aussi que la france regarde quelles sont
ses intérêts là où elle peut développer
économiquement ces entreprises et puis
l'état concerné sur le continent
africain dit lui bah j'ai aussi besoin
de l'entreprise française et ça va aider
montrant plus développement bruno le
maire virginie fait avec et auteur du
livre stratégie martin kihn e-marketing
à 6o de star ac une question à vous
poser c'est le défi numérique au fond
qu'est qui compte beaucoup pour
l'afrique ou si on l'écoutait monsieur
le maire la souveraineté numérique de
notre pays la formation dans le domaine
et l'innovation sont des enjeux majeurs
pour notre économie ma question est la
suivante dans les deux ans à venir
quelle serait votre plan d'action pour
servir ses objectifs et faciliter
l'accès à la formation au numérique tout
au long de la vie
je ne peux pas multiplier les exemples
et des réponses mais sergent votre
question sur l'afrique quand il est avec
thierry breton est présent la république
nous obtenons l'accord des 27 états
membres pour les déploiements une
constellation en orbite basse ça répond
à 100 sessions de numérique parce que ça
va permettre de couvrir en internet à
très haut débit
tous les états européens et tous les
états africains sur une base
complètement indépendante est
complètement autonome ça va créer des
formations ça va créer des emplois dans
le domaine numérique et dans le domaine
digital mais pour ça il faut un
engagement européen qui soit totale on a
obtenu sa hier en partenariat avec
l'afrique je suis sûr que ce sera au
coeur des discussions aujourd'hui du
sommet ue-afrique comment est-ce que
cette constellation qui garantit
l'internet à très haut débit profite à
tous les états africains est ce que vous
n'avez pas à traiter ou avoir traité si
vous appartenez à la prochaine majorité
du rapport des français avec le travail
notamment des jeunes est-ce que c'est
pas un sujet qui va se poser dans notre
société est ce que les 35 heures est ce
que le télétravail massif est ce que
tout ça n'a pas bouleversé la conception
qu'ont les français notamment les jeunes
ça rejoint ce que disait si tu es à tout
à l'heure par contre est-ce que c'est un
problème de société qui qui vous arrive
à lire en plein dans la figure
l'abscisse ça devrait prendre deux
sociétés j'aurais simplement qu'on le
pousse bien c'est à dire qu'on le pose
sans faire des leçons de morale aux
jeunes que je trouve je voudrais
sincèrement totalement insupportable le
côté a brisé qu'un soucis n'ont ils pas
de souci il pas de souci insouciance des
jeunes refusent un travail parce qu'il
ya pas assez de télétravail c'est le cas
pour 20 minutes qu'un exemple de ce type
parce que c'est un souci de 24 ans non
je suis dit non je viens pas travailler
c'est ce qui a désolé les travaux refuse
ce discours que je trouve totalement
rétrograde consistant à dire les jeunes
ne veux plus bosser deux montants alors
qu'est-ce qui bruxelles sinon c'est faux
les jeunes sont imaginatifs sont
créatifs ils sont volontaires au g4
enfant de 11 ans à 22 ans mais ils ont
envie travail et vous êtes leur amour
travail et éveiller votre église veulent
travailler différemment ils ont raison
quand ils vont voir restaurateurs et qui
disent moi je veux pas sacrifier tous
les samedis tous mes week-ends je suis
prêt à bosser je veux qu'un montant soit
bien organisé donc vouloir donner son
nom quand vous avez un jeune ouvrier que
j'ai rencontré il ya pas très longtemps
dans une usine automobile qui j'aimerais
qu'on écoute ce que j'ai à dire sur la
chaîne de production ce que ça peut être
intéressant il a raison quand vous devez
requins qui dit j'ai envie de
télétravail et je suis une femme j'ai un
enfant à travailler je travaillais et là
un jour par semaine mais ils ont raison
je préfère le discours ta patrick
pouyanné patron de total a fini dit il
faut prendre en considération les
attentes sociales des jeunes plutôt que
ceux qui vont faire des leçons de morale
aux générations est ce que vous allez
faire après bruno le maire on parle de
vous comme premier ministre emmanuel
macron jo je serai après dépend
totalement qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'il
vous reste à faire ce qu'il vous reste
au fond à conquérir mais ce qui reste
c'est la vie oui ça c'est rien de
l'écrivain mais politique qu'est ce qui
vous réveillerez mai et connie telle
hormis l'agriculture candidat à la
présidentielle c'est la réponse c'est
matinée 11 à ce personnel de l'homme ce
qui reste c'est la vie il ya que ça qui
compte et la visa loyers atteignant ti
les multiples elle voulait des late in
your 1 mais ça la vie ne se limite pas
un poste politique elle est beaucoup
plus imaginative et vaste que cela ce
qui compte pour moi c'est que pose la
république soit réélu dans quelques
semaines parce que je considère
qu'aujourd'hui il est le seul à pouvoir
présider bien aux destinées de la france
ensuite il s'entoura d'une équipe qu'il
a gérée zira librement et pour ce qui me
concerne je vous le redis la ville et va
si vous avez envie de faire partie de
cette prochaine équipe et moi j'ai des
envies multiples dont celle là vous
savez dans celle là ça peut être de
faire partie de cette équipe c'est autre
chose tout est ouvert je pense que les
français n'y attache pas d'importance et
ils ont raison ce qu'il regardait
beaucoup d'attention c'est qui va
présider aux destinées de la france à
partir de mai prochain je souhaite que
ce soit menée de mâcon merci bruno le
maire merci est d'abord de nous avons
réservé vos réponses à pierre moscovici
le premier président de la cour des
comptes hier qui a parlé de déficits
records pour à l'avenir pour notre pays
merci d'avoir été notre invité sur
tv5monde merci sylver garcia semaine
prochaine nous recelons anne hidalgo sur
ce plateau à tous merci bonne journée
[Musique]